well did you read the fouchy emails
yes the freedom of information emails
that's really crazy because well he
first of all he's admitting in these
emails that masks don't work
he's wesley yes yeah he talks about it
talked about it openly oh wait i didn't
know that part i know i only here's i
thought you were going to talk about the
uh that too but here's the thing but
part of the email was look part of the
masked conversation with fauci has
always been that at the beginning of the
pandemic he said masks didn't work but
then he said the reason he said that is
because there wasn't enough mass for
first responders and hospital staff and
he didn't he wanted to make sure that
the supply wasn't damaged so he said
that he didn't tell the truth right okay
but in these emails
he's also this is private emails he's
saying masks don't work
for real yes he's saying that they're
not effective for what you outside of a
hospital setting
these masks like for personal use the
kind of cloth masks and paper masks that
everybody's wearing they're not
effective they're not they can't exactly
what did he say let's let's pull it up
exactly what he said but that's not even
the big part the big part is he's
talking about gain of function research
in the wuhan lab and he's concerned
about it and thinking whether or not
they had paused that and whether they're
still doing that and he's trying to
connect the gain of function research in
the wuhan lab with this covet breakout
and whether or not that's where it came
from right and why is that a big deal
because that's they funded it the nih
funded these people who funded the gain
of function research in the wuhan lab
which means
they're responsible for funding the very
research that led to this outbreak if
that's where it came from
right so all this time when he's been
saying it came from nature there's no
way it came from a lab well you know
that's shifted right now everybody's
saying
from a lab right right right but they're
not confirmed
right but the evidence is pointing yeah
as it's most likely that it came from a
lap this whole time fauci has been
saying it didn't but you see in his
emails that he was concerned
well concerned but isn't that but isn't
that like just trying to figure out what
the information is not really because he
doesn't definitively know either right
there's a lot of indications according
to the email he's talking to another
scientist right and the scientist points
out the variables or the the the um
the components of the virus that seem to
indicate that it possibly came from a
lab
but
publicly he's been
out now dismissing that
because
yeah he's connected to the very research
they were doing there uh-huh it's really
complicated [ __ ] it's confusing because
rand paul's been grilling them have you
seen those things
hey girls
typical mask you by the drugstore is not
really effective in keeping out the
virus which is small enough to pass
through the material it might however
provide some slight benefit in keeping
out gross droplets if someone coughs or
sneezes on you i do not recommend that
you wear a mask particularly since
you're going to a very low risk location
see this is just him saying that these
drugstore masks are not really effective
but this is this is in an email after he
has said
publicly that you didn't have to wear
masks because they didn't really help
and then he's saying this and
after that he said well he wasn't
telling the truth there because he
didn't want people to buy all the masks
but then he's saying this after that
right in an email that they don't really
work but yet he's wearing them but
that's kind of like that's there is
shades in that there's like the gross
droplets gross droplets
and if you're in a low risk location
like what's his motivation to
like why would he
profess masks if he
thought
well because
the narrative is everybody needs to mask
up but why like well because it makes
people feel safer a it helps people get
back to work b and it obviously is
providing some benefit
something
listen this is my take on it something's
happening because the flu cases are down
so low oh yeah so is that because of
people wearing masks is that because of
social distancing because everybody's
kind of freaked out and stayed away from
each other for so long washing their
hands everywhere they go getting having
having purely everything i don't think
that every spot i don't think that's it
because it's a you're talking about
something that's airborne
well for that but for you to get a cold
you know
your hands and your [ __ ]
all those things all those things yeah
maybe but there's something something
there's very well likely something to
masks that maybe we weren't aware of so
even what he's saying there that it
might just keep out gross droplets yeah
but isn't it all about like viral load
because like that's the thing they say
about a hospital workers like hospital
workers when they're they're exposed to
so much right that's when they go
somewhere and they really get sick yeah
maybe that's what these masks are good
for what is this
yeah get that there you go um
which are the protective measures anyone
should take against the new virus do
mass work he said the vast majority of
people outside china do not need to wear
a mask
red the fouchy approved response a mask
is more appropriate for someone who's
infected than for people trying to
protect against infection
right
well i mean what's but like what's
my whole thing with all of this is it's
been very confusing we're all every
governor's making decisions everybody's
around the world is trying to figure
[ __ ] out and
calling a lockdown and calling not a
lockdown everyone's like unlimited
information trying to make the best
decisions that they can like i don't
think that
as a governor of a state you're making a
decision to screw up the economy on
purpose i don't think that i don't think
that fauci is talking about mass
to
like harm people you know what i mean
like i just feel like i feel like
they're just have limited information
and are trying to muddle their way
through the best that they can like what
that's not the real problem is the mass
thing it's a small problem the real
problem is this gain of function
research [ __ ] this is the the very
research that they were doing where they
were just what
they were juicing up these viruses to
make them more infectious and they were
practicing
like trying to use i think they use
human lung tissue and try to get the
virus to be
more the idea is
i mean i'm going to butcher this for
sure but i think the idea is when
they're doing this research they want to
find out what makes these viruses more
infectious and they were doing it on the
original sars as well yeah which has
like a 10
fatality rate wow it's very scary wow
this stuff is less than one percent yeah
that stuff is way worse yeah and
by doing this gain of function research
they run the risk of people getting sick
we just found out a couple of weeks ago
that in november of 2019 three workers
from the lab in wuhan
got sent home
and sent to the hospital rather really
ill with coronavirus-like symptoms and
this was before they had covid19 tests
right uh-huh so these people got sent
home i believe one of the guys wives
died
from kovid
and they think this was the initial
infection so these people in the lab got
sick so all this time while they were
trying to dismiss this lab outbreak
that had been hidden from us that these
three people in the lab got sick the
fact that
fauci had something to do with that gain
of function research and funding that
gain of function research that had kind
of been hidden from well that makes it
josh rogan exposed that but that makes
it seem like
fauci's like putting on scrubs and
walking down the halls of that place you
know what i mean like
is fauci really like in there like you
know what i mean like are you defending
voucher
yeah like i don't know
i think that he's been put up as a
someone we can take our fears and anger
and throw it at but is he like he may be
part of like you know these things are
huge like there's a big board of people
that decide what they're going to
research and you got to read these
emails you got to read these emails and
now read so do you think that he's evil
do you think no i'm not saying that so
what do you what do you say
i think someone [ __ ] up i think
they're trying to cover up the fact they
[ __ ] up uh okay i think the whole
reason why they've been saying that this
thing came from nature it's a natural
spillover
is i don't think they're saying that
because that's the most likely scenario
i think they were saying that because
they [ __ ] up right now they did they
didn't want everyone to know that they
[ __ ] up and i think having the
position of power and having the
position of authority that he had he
could say
it does no indication this came from a
lab
who is they who [ __ ] up like what is
this well the lab in wuhan for sure [ __ ]
okay so who runs that lab well i don't
know but i do know that the nih
funded an organization they gave money
to an organization which gave money to
that lab that's that's the official
story got it and this is the story that
paul talked about
when he was grilling fauci this is also
what josh rogan talked about right
journalists that investigated all this
what josh what rogan was saying was that
during the trump administration
everything was so chaotic
that they just kind of they were able to
restart this this kind of dangerous
research that obama had put the brakes
on
obama apparently like what the [ __ ] are
you doing uh-huh why are you why are you
making viruses more deadly oh really
stop
and then try to do this trump was over
there going home number one i'm the best
and they're like i got an idea let's
start that [ __ ] research back let it
fly
i don't know virus force some i mean
it's interesting because uh some it's
interesting news organizations are
ignoring it completely
and uh other organizations are attacking
it's that's when you see like whether or
not the news is really the news because
you see the difference between the way
the left-wing news is covering it which
is a lot of them are just out now
ignoring it yeah and the right-wing news
coverage they're constantly bringing up
these emails right pulling them out and
saying hashtag firefoxy and all this
different yeah yeah well that's the
thing it's like once you start once you
start um
calling out like this is our side's
thing like i saw that there was a
headline in the new yorker or the new
york times
that said why it's important to why it's
so important to figure out whether this
lab theory is correct or not
and it was like that was kind of the
first time i saw it in those
in those
papers oh no it wasn't it was in
newsweek a couple months ago no but i'm
sorry that was like the first that was
the first fire yeah yeah because you
said when you see it on the cover of
newsweek when they started to consider
it again yeah yeah but it was political
yeah it's totally political trump was
such he was such a polarizing figure
that and people hated him so much that
anything that guy said everybody was
like [ __ ] him let's go the other way
right he said it came from a lab that it
definitely didn't come from a [ __ ]
lab yeah well that's the problem that's
the boy that cried wolf
syndrome right it became like exactly he
kind of did that to himself
he just keeps saying such
crazy [ __ ] that everybody was just in
making it and calling out everybody and
yelling
meanwhile fauci just wrote a book so
he's releasing a book on this now
making money off of a book oh yeah and
he's also the same guy that told us we
wouldn't ever shake hands again
i think he's adorable though he's little
he's got like a little like a bronx kind
of thing going i got an action figure
somebody sent me a crouchy action figure
yeah
with a mask on it has a mask sitting on
my desk he's adorable he's funny he put
him out there he's like
you know there's like oh look
i would love to know
what that would like okay so if we're
trying to get into the truth of it which
is what we need right we need to know
obviously you and me are not going to
get into the truth of it please i'll
just you could tell me the fact right
now and i'll forget it by the next
subject
but if they're trying to figure that out
like who is behind wuhan like who is
making those decisions to do all this
stuff like and how far is that a global
thing like is the u.s a huge part of it
was
was norway really involved like who well
they have a bunch i don't know what it
is apparently that do this kind of work
yeah and they do uh different kinds of
work at different kinds of labs and the
real fear is that in like some labs in
the world some places in the world they
do weaponized virus work god which means
terrifying that's terrifying which is
terrifying they did that in russia for
sure we actually covered that on this
sci-fi show that i hosted years back oh
yeah it covered the idea of weaponized
viruses
but the thing that they told me when we
went to uh the cdc down in uh galveston
texas they have this big building where
they house basically every [ __ ]
terrible disease known to man big thick
ass walls and ventilation systems and
everyone's wearing spacesuits and me and
duncan are high as [ __ ] wandering around
this place
you brought duncan yeah i mean duncan
went down there oh that's great and uh
the guy was saying that what he's really
worried about more than anything is the
things that come from nature he's like
we could worry all day about weaponized
viruses and he goes
but the possibility of that is low
compared to the possibility of something
jumping from nature which is very high
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video and audio experience on
spotify you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data cost
all for free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes you just need to search
for the jre on your spotify app go to
spotify now to get this full episode of
the joe rogan experience